if my nose is where my dick is at
where's my dick then
[Music]
what's up y'all it's your boy renny and
i'm here to answer the internet
if you had to pick one person to be the
ambassador for the human race to meet
aliens who would it be i would send
denzel washington yeah yeah you can't go
wrong you can't go wrong with him if you
had one free throw and if you make it
you get a million dollars but if you
miss you never get to tex again would
you shoot it yeah yeah i'm i'm nice and
bold i'm gonna make that yeah i'm nice
and bold i'm gonna make that i'm gonna
make that i'm gonna take the shot i'm
hitting a good
eight out of ten i'm paying 8 out of 10.
all right yeah i'm shooting it i'm
shooting my [ __ ] if you miss it i mean
you don't see nothing about facetime or
calling
[Laughter]
would you rather wear rental clothes in
the summer or summer clothes in the
winter i'd rather wear summer clothes in
the winter not winter clothing in new
york summer i know that much that's a
setup for disaster would you rather
give up porn or sex for one year porn
for one year yeah yes i guess it depends
on how much you get laid yeah yeah
that's the thing you're doing good you
get my you get my answer
do you think you could beat any creature
on earth if you had two samurai swords
no yeah no not an elephant
oh gosh before you even get to like
slice on me what do you think is the
biggest or toughest animal you could
beat with the swords nothing over like
like 300 pounds you know what i'm saying
a wolf i think wolf would be like wolf
is a cuddle what was the cuddle what's
worse being a tall girl or a short guy a
short guy tall girls are usually
supermodels and stuff like that anyway
i'm saying like okay what if it's like
five foot tall dude like super tiny but
like
six foot eight girls six foot eight
talking like big chick tiny guy that's a
six six five six six five
that's attractive to me like that's
actually attractive even if i'm not that
so yeah because i'm like average height
but that's attractive to me stuff like
that yeah like would you rather be a
short dude or a bald dude
uh i might have to go bold when i'm
young yeah i might yeah i got a big head
but i'll be out
would you rather have no music for the
rest of your life or have all music be
sung by your significant other i'd
rather have it sung by my significant
other yeah yeah only the songs that i
want them to sing
it's better than no music i can't live
without no music man i i can't sing
along with her to kind of guide her no
no no it's just her i'ma take it man i'm
gonna take it i could coach her probably
i don't know
mary [ __ ] kill
the hottest girl from your high school
your hottest teacher the hottest of your
friends moms
married
the hottest teacher and then i would
kill the hottest of my friend's moms and
i would kill the hottest girl from high
school really and i would [ __ ] the
hottest of my friend's mom who's the
hottest mom go ahead and tell your
friend who is it david don't don't do it
would you give up an inch of penis
length for an inch of height
yeah i got some height to spin i got a
little bit of height to spare yeah yeah
yeah two three yeah would you rather
have dust pans for hands or sweat
smokers jelly it's okay like we could do
that we could do this sweat smoke as
jelly yeah
yeah i'm a sweaty dude i'd be covered in
head to toe and jelly yeah but like i
can shake that jelly off man i can shake
that jelly off those pans i ain't doing
[ __ ] with that thing came to wipe your
ass with dustpan how are you gonna roll
the paper like this but i am with you
like you gotta go away your ass yeah but
somebody could do that for you i'll do
dustpans as here yeah
would you rather
date a girl who consistently sneezes on
you or consistently fights during sex
consistently sneezes on you yeah
absolutely absolutely i'll take i'll
i'll do the sneezes
um i wear a long sleeve or whatever but
not farting during sex that's that's
just what are we doing here like
[Laughter]
would you rather have
your dick as your nose
or your nose
as your dick hmm
this is a this is a crazy one right here
but if you guys should it's
covered if if
aren't they the same thing would you
rather have your dick as your nose on
your nose as you did you either have
your dick right here it means like
you're having sex
with your head in the middle or or have
your nose down here
i'd rather have
my dick what's off my nose
if my nose is where my dick is at
where's my dick then
your dick is where your nose is at so
that means my dick is on my nose is that
yeah so it's like i guess it's maybe
just what's worse having your dick on
your face or your nose on you your nose
and your dick so like i rather have my
dick as my nose then yeah i wanna make
my dick as my nose something interesting
about that hope you enjoyed the ati with
renny make sure you subscribe to the
channel put on notifications comment
what guests and celebrities you'd like
to see on ati
also i'm sick so that would make me feel
better if you do that